journeys through space and time
ultra-high-resolution expression
profiling of long non-coding RNAs I am
Rachel Brown of lab rats and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the group on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you have any
technical problems viewing or hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problems through the green Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker marcel dinger had said
genome informatics laboratory at the
Gervin institute of medical research in
sydney australia he is also an associate
professor in the Faculty of Medicine at
the University of New South Wales I will
now turn it over to dr. dinger for his
presentation thanks Rachel so today I'm
going to give a talk on on a couple of
projects that we've been working on an
alibi 30 to the last of the last couple
of years so switch to the side
able to advance to the next slide
so so the human so the human genome has
when it was a first sequence about 10 to
10 to 15 years ago one of the main
surprises that came from this was the
surprisingly small number of our protein
coding genes and that the number of
protein coding genes was in fact almost
equivalent to the number of genes in
mouth and MC elegance in a nematode worm
and I've even Brady surprise perhaps was
the was the number of genes that were
available in sponged and in serious and
in other other organisms for us progress
to the next animation you can see that
so if we move on to the next slide what
is is that the traditional diagram in
molecular biology effectively indicated
that there was this transit transition
going from DNA to RNA into proteins and
that the concept of misconception was
was really what was revealed from list
was that they're actually many rnase
that were in themselves and physically
functional so if we move to the next
slide
you can see that there were actually a
large number of of RNAs that were in
themselves and truthfully functional the
most i guess well known of these was
exists which is involved in silencing
the x chromosome and females and air
another non-coding RNA and mouse that
was involved in silencing and finally
examples like need one which were in
fact for involved in in the Performing
substructures of the off selves so it
was clear that non-coding RNAs actually
have an amazing ability to function but
though it remained an outstanding
question which was just how many of
these long non-coding RNAs are encoded
in mammalian genomes we've had for the
next slide if we lose it firstly excited
as you can see the picture of what the
transcript don't look like was it was
really quite remarkably reformed by a
few major experiments that occurred in
the early 2000s which were attempted to
try and characterize the entire trip
transcriptome of mouse the first of
these was a large c DNA sequencing
projects that actually revealed that
there were tens of thousands of of
messenger RNA that intellect protein
coding capacity when you make these out
across the genome one of the things it
became really surprising was that in
fact of considering a genome as being a
kind of an ir islands in a in a desert
of and in sort of effectively in a
desert or in a sea is not much it became
clear that the genome was actually
largely transcribed into these
non-coding RNA and there's a typical
protein centric view of the world well
somewhat turned upside down by the
presence of all of these non-coding rnas
so if we go to the next slide
you can actually see that when we fast
forward into the future and it's there
which is really quite remarkable is that
there are now tens of thousands of snow
and rnase has been annotated in the
mouse genome and so when we started
looking at this information in the early
two thousand one of the things that was
evident was was to see how many of these
RNAs are actually expressed and where
they were expressed so in the first of
these examples we started looking at the
expression of these non-coding RNAs in
all sorts of different models and one of
those was the adult mouse brain and we
were able to actually track the
expression of of long non-coding RNAs
and specific regions as their male
sprained you go to the next slide you
can see they how are these how these
non-coding RNAs are expressed in very
specific times and in very specific
places we can move to the next animation
what we can see is the expression of
these in all sorts of different contexts
and places so the next study that we
were involved in was to try and look at
at how he'll add the stability of these
particular non-coding RNAs so one of the
surprising I guess controversies over
non-coding RNAs was the idea that they
were anticipated to have a very very
short half-life and in fact as it
happened the the nature of these of
these non-coding RNAs and difference in
different contexts actually showed an
amazing diversity of stability and that
although on average they were less
disabled in messenger RNAs they were on
the whole in extremely stable species
and word rapidly degraded by the genome
in many cases certainly no not
inconsistent with the type of spread of
stability you see in messenger RNAs
which in some cases can also be very
short so I must like that you that is
there now what you can see in the image
on the left is the remarkable difference
in expression levels of non-coding RNA
so it's been read you can see the
messenger RNAs and messenger RNA
an area to consume on average more
highly expressed than non-coding our
names and if you look on the panel on
the right the number of transcripts in
the genome that are expressed in adult
issues for example you can see that most
messenger RNAs are actually expressed in
all tissues in fact sixty-five percent
by the tall red bar of messenger RNAs
are actually expressed in all in all
tissues in contrast as you can see from
the blue bars the the majority of long
non-coding RNAs are very specifically
expressed their very particular tissues
and it and we usually see that this is a
a key characteristic of of non-coding
RNAs across all all animals that we've
looked in is that the den tends to be a
much higher range of specificity that is
non-coding our nation to be more
specifically expressed in more specific
types of dishes so one of the problems
that this raises is in RNA seek so in
the case of RNA seek one of the main
problems that we see is that the most
abundant one and a half percent of
transcripts end up soaking up or using
up fifty percent of all RNA sequence and
so while only one percent of read
measures at least abundant fully for
presenters to take the transcripts
certificate of the consequence of this
is that when you're trying to secret see
this low end of the population IE
non-coding RNAs you un DUP seeing only a
very very small proportion of personal
data set and what was announced to is
that you wouldn't technique hudson need
hundreds of millions of of reads to even
get one x coverage of of non-coding rnas
if we move to the next slide you can see
that what we didn't needed to do then to
consider was to find a way that we were
able to pole or explore the expression
of these very rare non-coding rnas in
other contexts so for example we
developed this method that before
in a cab to seek so no captcha see
combines capture arrays and
next-generation sequencing and provides
an approach through which were able to
sequence is very very scarce or a rare
transcripts so the principles of of
capture seek are actually very much an
elegance or very similar to 2x MC where
accepted in this case instead of
targeting protein coding genes with
harga ting regions of the genome using
simple capture pools or boats to draw
down the cdnas or or RNA that's being
expressed from these sort of small
silenced parts of the genome required
about the genome with as much less
expression so the principles in that
respect a very similar to normal XM
capture you design an array their target
certain parts of the genome take our
innate and at the cdna and rich this
population and then proceed through
normal next-generation sequencing if we
go to the next slide you can see waiting
for the next slide to come up and so
what you can see in the next slide is is
that these that this technique is also
actually surprisingly quantitative so it
can feel right is a concentration
gradient of of using standards in normal
RNA seek and as you can see at low
concentration levels you lose your
linearity and ability to quantify
transcripts very rapidly becomes very
inaccurate at higher levels of higher
concentrations it becomes very accurate
what you see in capture seek is the
officer patent it becomes nice accurate
of higher levels because the probes
become saturated and at low levels it
becomes much much more the is much more
specific and much more able to detect
low concentrations very very accurately
go to the next slide
right so what we can see in the next
slide is that the busiest census has
over over the expression of transcripts
so as you can see in the lower forty two
percent of transcripts we are now able
to capture much more of these so that
this part of the dynamic range of
self-expression that's that has a much
superior capture at this low end of
expression which is very very valuable
so this was this work was recently
published in in nature methods and the
cool thing about it is that then we're
able to effectively take a microscope on
to the start of the genome and examine
it and look at it the ways that were
formerly not possible so as we can see
me on the in the current slide what we
wanted to use this this particular
technology for us to try and investigate
what was possible of looking in Gio's
regions of the genome sergio's is a
method used for associating and
particular types of of disease variance
with regions in the genome when you so
called lv blocks now the vast majority
of the reasons had come in somewhat of
surprise in the thousands of g while
studies that have been done is that the
vast majority of these about 88 two ends
of them occur in antigenic or intronic
regions and can't be easily related to
any any protein coding gene so what we
did is that we is that we took these
regions of the genome about 300 awesome
and and move them if we took these three
hundred or so regions of the genome and
then we move them and created capture
capture pools of so that we were able to
target the transcripts that were coming
from these regions of the genome so the
question was was obviously too easy your
are they gone and one of the coolest
things that were able to do as a
consequence of that is able to look at
at the transcripts to come from so what
would be really what what's really
interesting is that if we now look at
this experimental design and the current
slide you can see that what we were able
to do was to be able to design this
array that an overlay
with any with any protein coding genes
and simply true down the information
that came from these parts of the genome
as you can see in the current slide so
in summary we were able to look at about
150 or so different traits and diseases
which spanned about 340 g wise linkage
blocks has covered about 50 mega bases
of the genome so when you think of the
genome being about three Giga bases and
size we were really only just looking at
the transcripts that were coming from a
very small region of this which goes are
very very strong in Riften ratio over
what conventional RNA sequences given us
we did this this process over 21
different adult human tissues so what
we've what we serve and i guess in
summary what you can see in this slide
is that the is the number of of
transcripts that capture a sequel able
to get our capture at at different
expression levels so she can see from
this F decay in values we actually saw a
very large number of multi exon
transcripts a few thousand across these
different tissues we only looked multi-x
on transcripts so that we could be sure
that there was no contamination coming
from from breck background so although
there were thousands of single exon
transcripts detected as well these we've
explored in there and the rest of the
analyses so about eighty percent or so
of the G while Kepler epitope blocks
that we looked at when covered by and
hot Kaufman's with these multi exonic
transcripts so as you can see in the
current slide about thirty eight percent
of these transcripts editor fpk ends of
over a hundred and these are actually
very highly expressed we also saw the
full range of other types of expression
expression middles and really across the
board as well and but there was only six
percent of the head per box that had no
expression detectable whatsoever in any
of the 21 fishes so our next question is
was is one of these jeans look like in
terms of tissue specificity how many of
these these transcripts were actually
expressed in very specific tissue types
so first of all
we divided these out across the
different tissues and as you can see
testes placenta and brain showed that
the largest number of transcripts that
were expressed in exclusively in these
particular tissue types so testes and
brain often come up in these types of
studies and has been shown before or to
a very large number of specific
transcripts the transcriptome of the
center is not as well studied and the
sudden had had not been previously seen
that or had been only very seldom
reported before that the center also
actually features a very large number of
completely unique transcripts that is
transcripts that Alex based in any other
in any other tissue in the body so next
question was do these transcripts or to
what extent of these transcripts
recapitulate or resemble messenger RNAs
so we looked at cage profiles h3k4
trimethylation and h3k27 trimethylation
SAT marks across these loci and compared
them to messenger rnas and indeed we
were able to conclude that the vast
majority of these that the vast majority
of these transcripts did indeed have the
same sort of signals as we would expect
to see from from regular jeans so it
seems that they're controlled probably
by similar architecture to mr. Jarrah
nades as you can see in the next slide
is that we next sought to to identify or
to work out what the what what the
nature was at the specificity of these
different transcripts so as you can see
from the heat map the vast majority of
the other captured transcripts with
specific to a particular heckler block
if you look at the system and tish this
for example you can see the majority of
the trench which occurred in only
tasters however when we looked at for
example spleen and thymus where there
were tissues that are actually quite
similar you get a stronger clustering of
around those those those tissues and the
transcripts that are associated with
them similarly when we looked in the
colon and small intestine Ventura gained
very similar tissue types they also
showed a
large or overlapping the same time
transcripts similarly in Muslim
esophagus Philippine overlap between the
transcripts which identified there so
it's important to note at this stage
that the vast number of of these
transcripts had never even had never
been seen before um in any other teen
database these were all completely novel
transcripts for the large part so next
question was is is if we're looking in a
disease model or in different types of
context what do we see then do we also
see the same level as business of
specificity recapitulated them in
different models as well which we
expected to so we look for example as
the expression of these transcripts in
melanoma so it is the same experiment
and use the same design and looked at
about 10 or so melanoma tissues to
identify and look at what transcripts
week were able to capture in sequence
there and whether these were whether or
not these these transcripts were unique
and these as you can see from the
current slide is that we were able to
identify dozens of different transcripts
that were completely expect it and
exclusively expressed in the homeowner
and in no other tissues and it moreover
many of these transcripts as you can see
in the lower quartile also in the lower
quartile of that slide were reproducible
in an independent tissue samples so our
next question was did we see
specifically expressed non-coding RNA
that were specifically expressed in
melanoma and also associated with a
haploid block associated with melanoma
with the idea that that perhaps we'll be
able to identify transcripts that were
important in this particular disease
etiology and that could explain a
disease association with this data for
genome in this disease so on the current
side that you can see on the red line is
the location of a snip and the blue bar
represents a perhaps overlock associated
with definite
the current annotations and refseq as
you can see there is an i5 44 and ELP be
one it shows that there was actually no
annotation and the starter for genomics
deliver as you can see from the from
these wiggle plots expression profiles
that came from me I think it was 12 or
so melanoma tissues is that were able to
detect very high levels of expression
coming from from this particular low
sigh and when we assemble business or
transcripts were able to find that the
referee a very large number of very
specifically expressed spliced long
non-coding RNAs arising from this
lockers and it would seem that this is
that a this would be potentially a very
good candidate to pursue as a as a as a
potential gene that's involved and
explained this particular disease
association in this type of the genome
so we were pretty happy with that and
thought that was quite a good result so
the next question is as well this
technology is obviously extremely
powerful and there are many things that
you could do it so I just want to spend
the next tues five going over a few
examples or what else you can use
non-coding RNA to look at so the current
slide you can for instance use it to
capture very specific types of and
recapitulate quite not in and pull down
very novel isoforms from from what would
otherwise be seems to single exons so
what you can do is if you create base or
a target towards the single exile you
can use it to complete transcripts so
that is if you had a transcription
you're not able to see anything else
from it you're able to pull it down and
then pull down the rest of the
transcript to make leg back to the
genome and in some cases were able to
take single exons and pull them and pull
out dozens of other exons and exon
intron boundaries from that so the
current slide can also use this to
refine annotations of Noah genes so in
this current example there were three
different genes known as CX two of which
were knowing or recognized open reading
frames but only one of them see hdcd CH
DC
to that that was really known and
annotated and there were two long
non-coding RNAs that sat in the middle
of these when we actually capture this
section tickets Rita pitcher is can be
assembled into one single kind of [ __ ]
transcripts that comprises of an open
reading frame that's thousands of amino
acids and Link so using that were able
to effectively refine existing
annotations so in the current slide you
could also use this really across the
board to identify massive numbers of of
new exons easier than knowing genes one
of the other experiments we did is that
we looked at at all cancer genes for
example and rover to pull these down and
and and define hundreds of new exons
even in very very well studied our
kitchens and tumor suppressors so the
amount of novelty really was was some
was very significant and really quite
exciting so as you can see in the
current side you can also use this to
pull down fusion fusion genes so for
example in the case of side bcl-2 you're
able to make targets towards bcl-2 and
then pull down all of the transcripts
that are associated for all the fusion
partners that was part of the genome
creates so you don't need to have any
other a priori knowledge about what
types of genes and bcl-2 can dissociate
himself with you're able to pull down
all the using this technique and
similarly with any of the other
potential fusion transcripts you're able
to pull down whatever else they fuse to
so in the next slide we also nixa today
an examination of chromosome 21 when we
created a specific capture pool their
targeted the entire chromosome and we
used us as an approach and then we use
brain and pistols RNA as an approach to
see if we could net if we could
effectively identify all transcripts
that arose from this particular this
particular part of the Gina and Pat
salsa
as a proxy to see how much expression
there really is in the genome so you can
see in the middle part of that panel the
gencode annotations and then it's
actually Cedeno would look for a fairly
sparse but if you look at the capture
stick data at the bottom you can see
that the these kind of islands of
transcriptions were coming really just
to come third the whole continents
really of expression is really possible
what this what this looks like in almost
every nucleotide in the in chromosome 21
is actually expressed in some context so
let's skip over to the next slide that
you can actually the other interesting
observation that we made was that in the
case of of non-coding RNA that there was
a a really profound number of different
transcripts that were could be
alternatively spliced from these
different exons so this was a an
interesting observation that we were
able to make almost generic so we were
able to identify both large numbers of
new exons and no in protein coding genes
but I think more importantly we were
also able to identify these that that
non-coding RNAs had vast numbers of more
alternative splicing against encoding
than coding genes did which was a really
interesting observation so what you can
see in the graph in the middle is that
although you reach saturation in the
number of alternate splicing events ie
by the number of coding introns that are
present in protein coding genes we don't
reach saturation of the number of
non-coding entrants so that suggests is
that the amount of diversity that's
created by alternative splicing in
non-coding RNAs is five basic protein
coat Garnett's what was being
evolutionary early or functionally is
not yet clear but it's certainly an
interesting observation photos think the
first half of this talk on was really
talking about was was looking at this
RNA capture sick method to be able to
really zoom in to zoom into the genome
inmates that were that if otherwise been
completely impossible but what we're
able to do
and it really opens up a whole sea of
possibilities of photos how complex the
transcript tenders and that we now kind
of to make the analogy of looking out
and looking out of space and in the
evening if you're in a busy city or
you're out of dusk you might not see it
on for a lot of stars but in fact you go
out into a into a more into a darker or
a environment outside of the city and
you'll see more and more stars it's not
because the sales weren't there
significance previously it was too dark
to see them and if you go take that one
step further and you think of a
technology like the Hubble Space
Telescope and you look at that and
seemed suddenly it becomes feasible to
see this remarkable and deep complexity
that is out there in the universe so
that's kind of cool me you can see how
beautiful the images are that actually
comes from this and to think that all
this is is already out there Justin it
requires like to see it so I think we
make a similar analogy to this when we
think about the transcriptome and that
we didn't we use a more sophisticated
tool we're able to see a far far deeper
level of complexity that was ever
otherwise imagined to be there and
certainly that has really transformed
the way that we see how the genome
encodes information and how this
information and trans actors to give
biological function so our next question
what's up well what about all the was
was asked that well what about all the
things that are transient what about
those those those types of non-coding
RNAs that appear at one time but then
actually expressed just briefly and then
disappear again today continue the
analogy of space kind of like a shooting
this siren in the sky if you blink
unisys what about transiently
transiently expressed a non-coding RNA
do we see a similar phenomenon where a
transcript is expressed for one period
and then disappears again and again
limited by technology that we're not
actually able to see it or catch it
effectively so to address this question
we did a study to try and investigate
what the effects are of looking is
longer at
at the transcriptome in a model of
development so in this case we looked at
embryonic stem cells as they
differentiate them dear boy bodies and
its really interesting what you actually
see happening in doing this so
previously in previous studies of of
embryonic stem cells which were sampled
approximately once every 24 hours which
is a very typical way that these
experiments we're done as you as you can
see from what actually happening during
development you may see this things that
are happening in between so our question
was as well how much exactly are we
missing by the existing sort of course
temporal expression profiles that we
used to looking at and so what we did
was push the next slide what we did is
take a full RNA seek samples across a
transcript terminix every six hours over
a five-day development of the seal over
the process of ESL development and then
we took the serenade and then stirred
RNA stinkin in the normal way and
effectively compared what happens when
you compare six our sampling frequency
to 24 hours after frequencies how much
information is lost by simply sampling
not often enough are basically too
infrequently solar slide you can see
that we are able to recapitulate very
nicely each of the domain transitions
that occurred during EP differentiation
so by taking this very high-resolution
temporal profile variable to identify
all the clusters of genes that are
associated with each of these
transitions as you can see the heat map
losing from left to right so one of the
cool things like that we looked at was
to M was first of all to look at well
what about the Nolan jeans whatever the
most well study genes in development and
what they look like when we examine
these leads context so the current graph
shows the expression of some of the key
transcriptional regulators that are very
well studied in ear cells so the result
there are showing as 24-hour lean issues
now if you look
a couple of these examples in this case
EDX ones and Lefty one you can see what
happens when we actually look at this
and in six hourly intervals instead of
24 hour intervals as you can see there
in the black lines that have now
appeared you can see that genes like EV
x 1 and unless you want it actually got
undergo some more quite remarkable
transitions in those those 24 hours that
you would ordinarily have never captured
and you can see by the discordance in in
other places as well on the other risks
to grasp that is this really quite
surprising differences that you can see
there which is which was unexpected and
very interesting the other thing you
might exhibit if you look at one side
power 5 5 s 1 and cxcr4 is that the seem
to be a sort of a cycling of some of
these genes happening and it seemed that
some of these that this was actually a
reproducible effect with some jeans seem
to go up and down even an entry to have
some sort of periodicity associated with
their expression so we sought to look
the genes across the genome that had
this characteristic of of cycling and
when we did this that's one of the first
jeans came out there was it was a gene
called clock which actually live in
which the annulment circadian gene which
goes up and down of time so again as you
can see if you're just looking at this
for twenty four-hour intervals that's
what actually has appeared as a gene
that was not freely expressed but when
we look at it in the very high
resolution temporal profile we're
actually able to see that this gene goes
up and down quite rapidly over this time
course and that we're able to identify
very dynamic jeans and reverse method we
also identify other genes that have got
different career disagrees so what this
was effectively telling us is that there
are actually many more differentially
expressed genes that you're able to
identify by just by increasing the
sampling frequency in the recapitulation
and trying to look at expression
networks or than other or regulatory
networks or another area that we were
able to explore in a and an amazing
amount of detail by using this method
and the slides you see here is a an
algorithm noms de re and that
effectively is a system where you you
look at different transcription factors
and you can see what the main driving
transcription factors are over the
course of process so again students at
24 hour intervals you get a very
coarse-grained view of of these key
bifurcations or steps where development
is transition from one stage to another
by the tens of transcription factor
profiles now when we do this at a very
high temporal resolution at the 6-hour
frequency what you can see is that even
very early on is in a really sad scene
dynamic transition happening as a
consequence of just looking at very
small numbers of transcription factors
and you're able to identify effectively
the sequence in which all of these are
things are actually occurring which is
really quite remarkable what were able
to do then is that it is actually the
start dissecting these these regulatory
networks in a very fine fine resolution
and able to effectively distinguish as
you like drivers from passengers so
you're able to see the things that
happens first and lessons in the
sequences this developmental cascade
unfolds so we expect that we're able to
use this type of technology for looking
in and other diseases as well as
chancellor for example and be able to
identify what the sequences have been
sorry and for example in team or
profession so undecided you can see
there another question that is going
back to London on coding Aaron age that
it be I guess prevailing for quite some
time was that when you look at the
genome you are see this pattern of anti
scenes for bi-directional transcripts
associated with protein coding gene and
those are often a question as to whether
these these types of transcripts were
coexpressed been switched on at the same
time or whether in fact that comer
switched on some of her time some other
times or they're just you get one
expresses in another expressed later so
you can see the side is the heat map is
effectively the result of looking at
this analysis
so what we did was look at the we took
all bidirectional transcripts in the in
the transcriptome and and graft them by
their correlation effectively a Spearman
correlation coefficient across all of
these these pairs they are so
surprisingly what we see is that those
transcripts that are very close to each
other are the most likely to also be
co-expressed but as you can see in other
parts of that of the same image that you
can see that there are actually live
standards of transcription that's the
interesting ones to focus on that are
very discordantly expressed and in some
some cases even negatively expressed
negatively correlated meaning that this
one is on the other is always off so
officers provided an effect a very
different way of of studying and looking
at the genome and the relationship to an
expression of a transcript and its
position in the genome one of the other
cool things that you're able to do with
us again using correlation is to do
identify the functions of transcripts so
in the case of long non-coding RNAs
whether that's really tens and thousands
of of these non-coding transcripts that
we don't know the functions of it's a
very very daunting task to think about
how how these transcripts which was
really got no handle on on being able to
predict their function how we were able
to dinner in some way into their
function so one of the ways of this is
done is using a kind of a so-called
guilt by association approach what that
means is that you cost us together those
those transcripts that follow particular
clusters of expression of protein coding
genes of melon function so we were able
to do this for all the main dynamic
transitions that could in this embryonic
stem cell development model and in doing
so anticipate or predict at least what
the functions of these long non-coding
RNAs might be so the idea is is that is
that transcripts that are co-regulated
they all move together effectively under
the same regulation and therefore
presumably have some related function
that in that context so you can see in
the current slide that we were able to
do this as a way of identifying the
functional of dozens of non-coding RNA
long non-coding RNAs that would
previously have no characterized
function so and so effectively what you
do is you you do a gene ontology looks
at in ontology enrichments of these
different clusters based on for Mel and
protein coding functions and then you
associated that back with with
non-coding RNAs that follow those same
developmental profiles expression
profiles and so in doing so we were able
to assign potential functions to lots of
transcript doesn't say the garbage funk
sure that these are conclusively those
functions but what it does tell us is
that there's no business are handled
upon which to our direction at least to
inform future functional studies it's a
very powerful method so the exterior
that we were looking at as well again
using a similar idea of using
correlation as a as a system to
potentially identify co-regulated parts
of the genome so obviously correlated
expression our expression effectively
created in expression matrix of of all
correlated expression reasons of a
correlated expression across the entire
genome with the view of basically trying
to go is there what are the
relationships between regions of the
genome where you've got a teacher even
on different chromosomes where you'd
like they're getting similar or highly
correlated expression and then we make
this back to genome structure so the
next slide pets get articulate what this
looks like so here we took for example a
specific cluster of transcripts that
will have regulate it and move down in
particular and as you can see them very
bar upon the cash on the list and then
we met these same transcripts back onto
the genome using them this in this case
you four circles plot so the
potentially telling us we actually see
the hundreds of transcripts are actually
coming from a fairly small level of low
say around the female and the suggestion
is is that perhaps then what's actually
happening is that these these these
specific types of transcripts are
actually all these specific parts of the
genome rather are all coming from some
common transcription factor e ora pulled
into some pho sigh in the nucleus and
under some form of common regulation so
in this way we can actually in essence a
third and serpentine what the 3d
architectural structures of the genome
trauma care for these highly correlated
expression profiles so simple of the
things that we're looking at now is to
see if this does affect corresponds to
hyphy data and which should we may
expect to see that these regions of the
genome are actually spatially connected
in the nucleus so the coincide you can
another example of this in this case we
took transcripts that all kind of bring
up over this period is taking the
feeling call screen view of this and
again an actor's back out across the
genome to see where these lows I came
from and again potentially there for
suggesting that these are these
particular so so around the genome in
some way connected in 3d space inside
the nucleus so with that I'll just
summarize some of those summer what else
what else what I've told you about over
the last forty five percent so there's
one of the prevailing I guess
observations that we make from all of
this work is that new technologies
really are a remarkable way of
effectively informing and defining our
understanding of biology in this case we
showed first of all that our view of the
transcriptome changed amazingly in in
light of the development of tiling
microarrays much scale cdma expression
profiling and then transforming this
into RNA seek and then capture seek and
as each of each time we see these new
technologies our viewer and our
understanding of the informational
content if Regina continues to be
transformed and again by even looking as
these types of technologies become more
and more accessible like Aaron a second
assistant
we're also an see that even these types
of technologies again redefine and the
way and we imagine that you know a
translational genomics included
certainly a theme across the board that
long non-coding RNA is very specifically
expressed and the perhaps this also
explains to some extent why they as
agent detection in the first place and
why they've taken such a long time to
discover I basically didn't have the
tools to see them we firmly believe that
these these types of Venice's exactly
descend qualities that made these
transcripts harder to text they also
make them incredibly attractive or very
attractive potentially as as both
biomarkers and potentially associated
targets that is if it is true that these
long non-coding RNA they are in fact
involved in specifying particular sub
cell types and therefore also
potentially involved in in driving or
causing disease in some contexts we may
be a also able to target those parts of
the genome for those transcripts are
very very specifically without causing
sort of them I guess other secondary
effects in other parts of the of an
organism vorticity potentially very very
powerful and certainly just to leave you
with the idea that this type of
high-resolution transcriptome profiling
is potentially a very transformative
approach in understanding and
effectively taking a real systems
approach to understanding regulatory
networks regulate and and in complex
biological systems so we sort of
positive ective lead at this type of the
type of sequencing this height of
resolution temporal profiling could be
used in many other contexts as well so
as I mentioned before they had some
things like cancer progression for a
drug response or or even you could even
envisage in the case of something like
any sort of wild-type knock knock out
experiment where you can look at a
gradual change in transition by
capturing many many points you're able
to infer and also a lot more about the
biology the texture underlying
incisions if you only have a before
after shot it effectively makes it very
limited in what you're able to analyze
so with that I'll just leave just
acknowledge my laboratory and people who
did that most of its work because this
is a picture taken in Australia after
playing lawn bowls which you're
obligated to do with Stefan this is
brian and best fitted most of the work
really drove the work on the last part
of the talk on temporal expression
profile and and the Ned baton check who
did all the work on the RNA capture seek
this work was also done in collaboration
with 10 vs lab and dogmatic sled who put
an awful lot of local cell into the
capture speak to seek space and in fact
I'm happy to take any questions thank
you great thank you so much for that
informative presentation after dinner
now before we get started on the
question and answer session I would like
to remind our audience how does it make
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window will try to answer
as many questions as you can and our
first question is from Tammy from the
University of Toledo since there are
many different classes of long
non-coding RNAs are the tissue-specific
transcripts all representing a specific
type of long non-coding RNAs right ok so
it's an interesting question that is
something that we haven't specifically
tried to break down yet so we don't
actually know it's also a lot at this
stage about what the different types of
classes as long non-coding RNA they
actually look like so they say what are
the things that makes it very difficult
to study them because there are no no
and protein or you know they're
effectively unlike protein coding genes
where we've got circular motifs where we
can we can associate or breakdown
classes for example to transfer it from
transcription factors or RNA binding
proteins or or membrane proteins for
example we don't have any any
similar way really of breaking down
different classes of non-coding RNAs so
we have next been able to to really
provide much more resolution to that at
this stage great our next question is
from Steven with the DNA fiber Cancer
Institute yes why would the center in
type testes have a block of transcript
transcript in common ok so I think
what's happening there as my impression
at least is that some of these types of
tissues like testers and antler center
has a very very premise of transcription
that is large proportions of the of the
of the transcript don't seem to be
expressed in in the game are in these
types of tissues so I don't actually
know that it's incredibly well
understood having this is the slide that
we're talking about here is is that
makes me very well understood why it is
exactly that that testa simpler seem to
have such premise of transcription but
yeah they certainly do have at least
some of their transcription profiles and
comments I don't know if it's the
consequences I guess a very open
transcription and therefore more likely
to see college jeans or wizards or
something else that that's relating
those two things I have one more
question and do these islands of
correlate with specific chromatin marks
right okay said that that's an
interesting idea so we don't have a
chromatin chip data over the same data
set which so we can't actually answer
that question because we don't have the
data get to it so but it's a really
interesting ideas oh my expectation is
that is that that is what we would
expect to see is that is that there's a
common regulation between those those
parts of the genome that are being
basically transcribed at the same time
and that they have common regulatory
drivers and therefore potentially have
similar epigenetic marks as well but
there's something we haven't been able
to look at because you'd effectively
needs to chip seek over the center over
this
across the tunnels as well we have time
for one more question um perfect I think
perhaps is in marrying the 3d structure
from the circus history yeah and
ferrying the 3d structure I think it's
very pretty structure mr. Costa okay
that's like that okay so she asks is
there a way to evaluate how this
correlates with my crystal TV studies
right so yeah I think that there is I
think that what we really like to be
able to do next is to be able to now
take some of these transcripts that we
expect or are predicting are expressed
in the in these kind of I guess common
in this common regulatory architecture
and then being able to to identify from
there whether it's in first we were able
to label those using some sort of flesh
experiments we would expect that we
would see them being cooked co-localized
in the nucleus as well so again so
really it's a really cool idea it would
be a wonderful experiment to do would be
in fact here to take some of those those
candidates and bring them together and
and see if they are indeed co-localized
or expressed in the time and space as
well okay great so thank you dr.
Jennifer presentation and that is all
the time we have left today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through November 2015 you perceive an
email from lab roots alerting you when
the webcast will be available for replay
we invite you to afford that
announcement to your colleagues you may
have missed today's my event see you
next time goodbye everyone thank you